- [Narrator] Sweden wants to
join NATO as soon as possible.
The Nordic country
applied for a membership
at the same time as Finland last year,
shortly after Russia launched
its full-scale invasion of Ukraine.
But while Finland was accepted this April,
Turkey, and Hungary are
blocking Sweden from joining.
Let's look at what's
holding up the process
and what Sweden can bring to
the Western Military Alliance.
Sweden is strategically located
next to NATO's newest member Finland.
If Sweden joined NATO,
troops would be able to go through
Swish territory into Finland,
to defend the 800-mile-long
border with Russia.
- Those two countries, along
with Norway and Denmark,
formal type of Nordic
fortress in Northern Europe,
which helps NATO sure up
its defenses against Russia,
both over land, but also
at sea, in the Baltic Sea.
- [Narrator] The Baltic Sea is
the shortest direct waterway
from Russia to the West.
This is where Sweden's,
Gotland Island is located.
NATO often conducts
military exercises here,
and the island could be used as a base
to protect its naval
forces in Northern Europe.
- By joining nato,
Sweden also reinforces the
alliance with weaponry.
It has surface-to-air missiles,
which will help NATO
bolsters its defenses,
its air defenses in this region.
In addition, Sweden also has submarines
for the Baltic Sea,
and have a deep knowledge
of Russian affairs
having been so closely located
to Russia for over decades.
In a way that many
European countries haven't.
- [Narrator] For centuries,
Sweden avoided taking part
in military conflicts,
but the country has worked closely
with the alliance in the past.
- Sweden has had a close
partnership with NATO
for several decades, going
back to the mid-1990s
where Sweden was part of the NATO mission
in Bosnia Herzegovina,
and then since then,
it has participated in various
NATO missions in Afghanistan,
and it's been part of what's called
an Enhanced Opportunity Partnership.
- [Narrator] But Russia's invasion
of Ukraine in February 2022,
made Sweden rethink its
policy of non-alignment.
Russia opposes NATO membership
for Sweden and Finland,
and said, "This would have consequences."
- Swedish and Finnish
intelligence services
are prepared for increased cyber attacks,
increased espionage.
They say they're not concerned
about direct military action
at the moment,
but Russia has threatened both countries
that there would be
consequences if they join NATO.
- [Narrator] Every NATO member
needs to approve Sweden's
application to join,
Hungary and Turkey are against it.
Hungary's Parliament says
it's because of what it calls
unwarranted Swedish criticism
of its democratic record.
While Turkey accuses Sweden
of sheltering Kurdish militants
that Ankara reconsiders
to be terrorists.
- Sweden made a number of concessions
to Turkey to address these concerns,
including passing a new
anti-terrorism law in Parliament
that made it illegal to be a member
of a terrorism organization.
And that includes the PKK,
which is a Turkish militant group
that Sweden also labels as
a terrorist organization.
(crowd chanting)
- [Narrator] Hundreds of
people protested in Stockholm
against the new law
saying, "The Swedish Government is bowing
to Turkish pressure."
Turkish President Recep Tayyip Erdoğan
asked Sweden to stop the protests
before he can agree to their membership.
NATO's Secretary General
called a meeting with Sweden and Turkey
to try and sort out the issues
before the Alliance holds its
Summit in Lithuania in July.
(dramatic music)